c'est quoi votre vie aujourd'hui
j'en ai plus moi j'en peux plus je n'ai
plus de vie c'est à dire je ne peux plus
sortir de chez moi je peux plus
recommander de couches chez moi parce
que le livre me reconnais je peux juger
plus de famille j'ai plus d'amis j'ai
plus rien mais c'est pas grave je suis
pas ici pour faire la différence
mais c'est grave j'ai tout de suite une
question excusez moi mais pourquoi
avez-vous refait il ya là il ya deux
jours cette vidéo qui remet de l'huile
sur le feu
suivre ses juges avaient j'essaye de
vous suivre de pur bon sens à donner à
des manières il a alors j'ai
l'impression voilà bien vous entendre
je savais que ça n'allait pas du tout
est de mon côté avec ça n'allait pas du
tout à apaiser la haine je le savais non
parce que la première fois
que vous ne mesurez y est parce que ça
allait ramer d'agnac m'a pas choisi
départements bas mais là aujourd'hui
selon divers bâtisse sur youtube heures
identitaire et catholique déjà quand
vous avez réagi que vous avez la
première vidéo j'ai reçu des centaines
de fois en fait oui alors il ya
plusieurs choses alors pour répondre
d'abord à votre question il faut
comprendre parce que c'est vrai que pour
certains on peut avoir du mal à cerner
en disant peut-être cesser qui réunit
enfin c'est une danse il fait avec une
danse c'est pas grave etc oui oui toi
quand tu danses chez toi ou la boulange
de quoi perso je m'en fous tu vois tu
fais ce que tu veux ce que tu comprends
pas c'est qu'une église pour des
chrétiens c'est un lieu sacré ça veut
dire que pour nous ça nous peine moi
c'est de la peine que j'ai reçu ça me
fait du mal de voir ça franchement c'est
comme si j'allais nantes et toi c'est
comme si j'allais dans un lieu que
j'allais chez pas dans ta chambre
d'enfants sous sur la tombe d'un de tes
proches etc et que je faisais c'est
comme ça
alors si ça a été dans une agonie sur
une mosquée ça m'aurait plus mis en
colère pour le coup parce que ça
m'aurait moins peiné puisque forcément
c'est moins sacré pour moi mais par
contre j'aurais trouvé ça dégueulasse
tout autant là pour le coup c'est plus
la peine qui prend le dessus parce que
voilà c'est quelque chose qui nous est
chère qui est sacré et en fait tu
t'attaques directement à nous et en plus
on se sent impuissant parce qu'on peut
rien faire pour te répondre parce
qu'évidemment tu t'entoures d'une armée
d'avocats on fait toujours très
attention à ce qu'on m'a dit en me
disant faut pas que ça donne dans la
menace faut pas que sa tendance à mais
en fait ya là il ya la colère qu'il a
mais par contre quand vous dites alors
oui il ya beaucoup de gens qui demandent
pourquoi t'as fait ça je comprends pas
pourquoi tu as fait ça mais toi tu y
ailles répondu tout seul sur twitter tu
l'as bien dit hein j'ai fait mon petit
buzz sûreté pmp et ma petite victime
pour être protégé de toute façon les
cathos n'ont rien dans le slip mdrrr ya
rien à craindre
et d'inconnu à star dans la mort tu as
aussi dit je chie sur l'islam et le
christianisme c'est le problème des
lotos boto mise et s'ils sont offusqués
c'est parce qu'ils savent bien au fond
que c'est des conneries leur religion 6
guère passionnante et c'est facile non
non j'ai été faire vérifier regarde et
on compte armand qui soit bonne pour eux
parce que je savais que tu allais dire
ça j'ai commenté justin christianophobes
c'est clair et net alors là je suis
content je suis content que tu reviennes
sur le fait que tu dises que c'était pas
pour défendre contre l'homophobie et que
c'est assez bien sam tu vois tu pouvais
même pas besoin de le dire que tu es un
menteur donc la droite a menti cette
fois-ci tueur mon nom je comprends tu es
jeune tu es un gamin tu veux faire le
buzz tu te tu t'exposes alors un tien
des reçus tu vends des photos de toi nue
sur internet et tout et je pense qu'un
jour tout ça c'est tu vas te rendre
compte que tête que tu as fait une
connerie là tu dis j'ai plus de vie donc
déjà tu vois ton compte moi ça me fait
de la peine pour toi et en tant que
catholique bien sûr j'ai de la colère
que je pourrais très bien le dire
en fait on tant que
catholique j'ai envie de prier surtout
pour que pour sa conversion et pour
surtout pour que peut-être ils se
rendent compte à mon avis c'est pas à
nous de faire ça je pense que il ya
beaucoup de français qui pensent qu'en
fait il ya juste ton père qui devrait
remettre une tarte et te dire arrête de
dandiner et va travailler parce qu'en
gros c'est ça là on est en train de
parler et des millions de français sont
en train de parler d'un truc en fait
c'est une connerie de gamins qui est
qu'à raqqa rien aux services appris ça
mais maintenant il faut pas que ça oui
mais maintenant là on est en train
d'inverser le trident dans le pot cindy
tim hill et larmoyante c'est la
christianophobie c'est un fait d'assura
verrez c'est même la première religion
attaqué en france l'année à 8700 acte
christianophobes 500 églises qui ont été
menées mais cimetière qui ont été
profanées 250 agressions anti chrétiens
en france c'est plus que n'importe
quelle autre religion c'est pas un
concours évidemment puisque les
chrétiens sont plus représentés mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il ya quand
on dit oui quand il dit vous vous rendez
vous validez le hockey et c'est celle ci
valident les choses mais on pourrait
faire la moue la même rapprochement avec
110 ans quand vous validez ça c'est
aussi un pas envers ensuite on va casser
des crucifix et ensuite on va attaquer
des églises etc en avoir et non mais je
ne dis pas ça c'est ça autant rien à
voir que quand eux deux ils disent ok
que tu dis c'est bien mené à ma mort ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'on peut faire
la même
vers la même destination donc là c'est
déjà de la profanation il faut que tu le
comprends ça c'est déjà mais si toi tu
mets dans le mot confirmation que
vérifiera l'étymologie c'en est déjà
donc c'est grave pour nous il faut que
tu le comprennent géraldine maillet moi
j'étais pas là vendredi j'ai regardé
attentivement mes camarades et je vous
ai écoutés alors vous avez exactement
l'âge de ma fille et effectivement si ma
fille faisait ça j'avais une petite
conne et je pense que j'ai vraiment
j'essaierai de la remettre sur le droit
chemin parce qu'effectivement je trouve
mais attendait parce qu'après je suis
plus aimable avec vous l'espère parce
que je sais pas si c'est une question
d'éducation de déviance auvray perdu
mais vous êtes le porte parole de
personnes à part peut-être de votre de
votre perdition et vous êtes finalement
le symptôme de l'époque je trouve moi
mais mais après j'ai été mais hyper
choqué c'est à dire qu'on a eu mille ha
et maintenant on à benjamin et on trouve
ça normal et en fait on trouve ça normal
de dire oui enfin oui mais en même temps
enfin c'est choquant mais en même temps
ne faut pas le menacer de mort c'est pas
bien ce que vous avez fait je n'avais
mais en même temps le ce en même temps
ce nom mais pas d'huile sur le feu ce
c'est pas possible c'est insupportable
parce qu'on jette en pâture et en fait
on mois pour moi excuse moi daniel mais
moi j'étais super choqué parce que moi
je suis croyante aussi comme toi et moi
ces images je m'en fous que ça me choque
ou pas en fait il faut pas mettre la
religion ne sais pas c'est pas ça crée
ce n'est pas au dessus tout la religion
c'est la religion c'est à ce faire un
team cette affaire privée tu vas pas
aller dans une église parce qu'il a mis
un crop tort que tu as dis oh là là
quelle horreur il a mis dans un crop top
il ya mi octobre c'est dégueulasse non
en fait on s'en fout ta religion c'est
un truc privé c'est un truc intime moi
ça n'a pas ébranlé ma foi ou pas ma foi
donc je trouve qu'aujourd'hui en faisant
ça on s'attend qu'à à son en s'attaquant
à benjamin finalement on le fragilise et
je pense que ça montre que justement
aujourd'hui notre société elle est
pourri parce qu'on donne justement la
parole aux intégristes à tous les
intérêts de toutes les religions mais a
fait le jeu tous les ans je suis désolé
de vous le dire mais oui mais oui bien
sûr voire humiliantes comme jeudi
le sont pas du tout là c'est vous qui
donnez des leçons catholique en disant
votre religion elle doit être intérieur
et c'est à nous à l'église est sacré le
christ lui-même dans l'évangile a chassé
les marchands du temple avec des cordes
quand ils profané le temple donc c'est
un aussi le devoir des chrétiens de
défendre les églises qui est un lieu
sacré qui est la maison de dieu après je
ne dis pas que là ça doit rentrer dans
le débat c'est juste une petite aparté
que les gens quand elle demande un jeune
homme est un geste qui fait un nom il
doit être proportionnée
on